what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to kevin samuels is gay
um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily
videos um
please subscribe guys i'm moving to
england in like a couple weeks and oh my
gosh
i'm so stressed out
with money and stuff like hit that
subscription button it helps me out it
helps the algorithm
just help help a girl out okay
all right i'm about to watch it [ __ ]
fabulous
this is gonna be a [ __ ] fabulous show
[ __ ] fabulous that's right
so here's what we're gonna do
guys ladies and gentlemen i'm gonna ask
that you guys
keep the likes
the engagement up over 50
so i don't have to stop and start stop
and start stop and start
let's put this there
let's put this out the way right there
so we have to stop and start stop and
start stop and start
we have five we should have already had
like 5 500 people in here
5 500 likes and we're a little [ __ ]
we're a little bit shy
so let's get them up
is can everybody hear well
testing testing one two three four i'll
go home and get your [ __ ] shine box
what's going on make sure
big shirley
ah showing i showed missing big shirley
she ain't been by here in a minute you
know they gotta sell on collard greens
hot wheels
you know when they got themselves on the
ground kevin what are you talking about
like what
you can count enough to be around
so before we get into it let's get
everything going you've got the
comment section
up and ruby
the comment section is up and moving it
is only to it is set to members only so
if you want to become a member and use
the chat room privileges you must select
a level
that's number one
number two
don't get carried away in there with
what y'all were talking about
i got a topic tonight and i want to talk
about it a very serious subject
something that i've been trying to avoid
something i've been trying to just kind
of
keep swept under the rug just kind of
just
keep doing what you do right
but unfortunately you know
the internet being the internet people
are who they are
people just want to allow you to live
your personal life in peace
and um
it's about time that i come clean
so
it's about time that we have this
conversation in the light of day so
we can have this and we can address it
answer any questions
so
we don't have to bring this topic up
ever again
okay
so um
moderators
make sure that the chat room stays
free of debris and trash
free of debris and trash as we get into
this sensitive topic
because that's exactly what it is you
know
some people are probably going to be
shocked tonight at some of the things
that they hear
um
but you know
it's all good
it's all good when it's all said and
done
it needs to be talked about it needs to
be discussed
i'm on the edge of my seat kevin
get to it oh my gosh and if i'm gonna do
it before any scandal or anything like
that breaks out
before you know the exposed videos start
coming out
before all the
oh my god oh my god you know kevin
samuels this kevin samuels that
that's what it is it's time to discuss
this oh yes say hello to bentley bear
baccarat bear we don't know what this
name is yet
so um sorry guys i'm a perfectionist i
just hate seeing stuff all over the
place
so um
guys
if you've been watching me for any
length of time
this probably should not be as a
surprise to you
i'm a stylish guy
yep i'm a stylish guy
and when you're a stylish guy
there oftentimes people just don't
understand they just don't get it
so um
there are other things that come along
with being an image consultant and a
stylish guy you know
uh let's put that there let's not toy
with that
all right you guys ready
you guys ready
all right so
for those who don't know my name is
kevin samuels i'm a professional image
consultant my job is to make sure that
you look good smell great on the best
version of yourself each and every day
and
uh as such
an image consultant concerns himself
with
image four parts of image appearance
behavior communication digital footprint
most people think about images they
think about just your appearance but
there's more to it than that
but to be a good image consultant
like a certified image master at my
level
you must heavily study your craft
and you must be well versed
in many different things including
women's fashion
men's fashion anybody that you're going
to anybody that you're going to style
you must be burst in
that's just the reality okay
and
if you if you don't know
that image and style
is
in these days it's dominated
by people in the lgbt community they're
dominated by a lot of gay men
uh matter of fact my favorite designer
tom ford
is a gay man he actually lost his
husband
yesterday said
um
and
with all the things that have been going
on today
the last
year
i've decided to stay out of beefs to
have a controversy out of confusion just
keep focused on what i'm doing keep
focused on what i'm doing because people
are always going to chitter chatter
always going to talk talk talk talk talk
but this this is something that i've
been trying to avoid
for the longest
but it just won't go away
it simply will not go away
and as such
um the way you handle it is you just
address it
okay we got to get the likes up we
should have already have over 8 000
likes so come on man
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well
lucky for me i'm not watching live so i
don't have to like anything
so let's go ahead and address the
elephant in the room you see the title
of the show
kevin samuels is gay
um
and it's time to go ahead and address
this
but before we get into that let's go
ahead and check to see what that means
game
a person
who is homosexual especially a man
that's the adjective
all right
and then the dated reference is
light-hearted or carefree
the noun is a homosexual person
typically referring to a man
so it's one thing to say you know nan
had a gay disposition and a very pretty
face that's a bygone error people don't
use the term gay that way anymore the
way people use gay today is really to
discuss
a man and his sexual preacher doesn't
matter what his sexual orientation was
is i mean even if he is gay
does it matter who cares
uh and sexual orientation
the capital is popular destination for
gays and lesbian all over the world
all right so that is what is often being
discussed
you know monday night we talked about
you know when people want to talk about
my content my platform the first thing
they want to do is run to the fact that
kevin samuels hates women he hates women
he hates black women in particular
and inevitably
they also try to bring this point
together too
he does all of the stuff that he does
because he's secretly a gay man
he's secretly in he's secretly a gay man
who hates women
yeah
he's secretly a gay man who needs to
come
out
he needs to come out of the closet
that's that's what that's what they will
tell you that kevin samuels is a gay man
and the reason he goes so hard about the
things he does because he needs
he's a gay man he's a gay man and you
know what to that i say
well
no
no
no no no but the answer the question
though
to answer the question that everybody
came here to find out are you a
homosexual
[Music]
am i a homosexual meaning do i have sex
with men
no
sorry to disappoint to my critics and
detractors i don't have sex with men
don't have sex with men
don't have sex with men don't have sex
with men i know i know i know i know i
know some people out there just shocked
they cannot believe it
there is no way
that six foot four
well-dressed man
has to be
has to be has to be gay
oh jesus christ
he has to be gay
because if not
what's going on look what the
homosexuals have done to me
just look what the homosexual has done
to the black woman's image he has to be
gay
he's a closeted homosexual man
well
funny thing is
i use my real name
and in 52 years i you have yet to see
any of my critics and detractors bring
out any
any shred of
proof for their allegations
and i live in atlanta
but yet they still say
they still serve my god
let's get through all that what
no matter where you meet a stranger be
careful if they are too friendly one
never knows when the homosexual is about
[Laughter]
what is it with people's occupation
black people in particular
to turn a heterosexual black man gay why
are we so homophobic
i've addressed this so many times but we
gotta get to the point
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's say let's get right down to it why
why is this so prevalent
well let's talk about it calling me gay
let's be honest
gives black women
access to the best insults
calling a black man gay automatically
gives black women
and
loser black men because here's the thing
you never get caught gay
by a man
who is beating you
you always get called gay by somebody
who you are beating
that's that's that's what that's what
that's what that's so true okay you know
what i think about when like there's
breakups and stuff
the louder person is always the one
that's the most hurt
and it's usually me i'm pretty sensitive
so
but like seriously like the louder
person in a breakup is always the one
that's the most hurt it's the same thing
with what he's saying like the person
losing in a fight is the one that
insults the other
uh slander is for
it's to even the odds
you never see somebody that's up here
saying oh yeah yeah oh yeah you get
because they don't care one way or
another their head
but it's it's always used to bring you
down and why is it used to bring it out
because it opens up all the all the best
insults i mean what do you get to say
sugar booty
uh butt bandit i mean all kind of i mean
just think of all the
i will tell you black women have made an
art form
out of defaming heterosexual black men
by calling them gay and using the words
i mean it's it's damn near jazz
and i will say to the women who are so
good at this and we presume you're women
if you were half as good at keeping a
man of value as you are of tearing and
being down you might have a life worth
living
i mean i want you to think about some of
the energy that gets put into this oh
look at him over here kitten heels and
this and that and such and so forth and
i gotta admit you you can have all of
the best insults but like i said the
other day if you choose to sit in this
chair and do and do uh content
there is no way you can do two to three
hour streams for five days in a row for
years
there's no way you can put out
thousands of hours worth of content
photographs and this net and if you want
to you can catch somebody anywhere you
can take a frame i guarantee i could
take i i could go through your life
and take a frame
no that's so true
in creating content like
you can't
you can paint people in such a different
way just based off of a couple of
classes a video or a photograph and make
you look any way i want to well kevin
what's the problem you may not be gay
but you sure look suspect
suspect meaning what
suspect meaning what did i [ __ ] men in
the ass
is that what you're trying to say that i
insert my penis in a man's ass is that
what you're trying to say this is gonna
be an adult's dream is that what you're
honestly i guarantee
you wouldn't walk up to me and say that
oh maybe maybe it's the other way around
i'm a no that's right
listen to some of these alpha
angry females and i'm a bottom i don't
insert i take see and that's the point
they get access to all of the best
insults your top your bottom your dish
your that's your son and if you try to
sit around and fight all of these
allegations you go crazy that's why you
just leave it alone
women who are winning at life don't tend
to
have to worry about stuff like that but
what really bothers so many
women who throw this out is because i'm
the kind of man i represent the kind of
man that a lot of these women would like
to get i'm not saying i'm the man
but i represent that guy a tall
good-looking
accomplished professional black man
i may not be your particular cup of tea
but let's not trip
i've heard women oh he looked this way
he looked that way i'm like now wait a
minute
i look better than you and i'm a man so
you told can't say nothing about
but i get it
calling me gay
gives you access to the best insults and
you and i tell you they use it to an art
form they use it to an art form and well
look you got a bracelet you got a ring
you got to watch you carry a purse you
diss you that you
all that sure right mm-hmm
produce one shred of proof one shred of
evidence well we don't have to oh i just
know he looks like it see that's what
we're at in the black community evan had
this argument with the uh with the guy
at a car dealership over this russell
westbrook stuff
and this dude was like man uh he wears a
dress he's gay and i'm like russell
westbrook ain't gay he's greater than me
man
he's not gay he is gay man i was like so
you're saying the man has sex with me
and right there
is when he should have shut the [ __ ] up
and said no i'm not saying that but
instead what did he do like most people
in our community you double down on your
ignorance well i'm just saying the men
that i know don't do that are you saying
the man has sex with are you trying to
say the man has sex with men
and then instead of just admitting oh
man you know what i'm just being
hyperbolic i don't like it it bothers me
no he went ahead saying
yeah he does or how can you say that you
know you know what he said i can't say
that nobody knows what anybody does
behind the scenes and i'm like well for
that case you're gay
no i'm not gay well yeah nobody can say
for sure what you do 100 percent of the
time and you're wearing a pink tie
when my grandfather would see you
wearing a pink tie and he would say
you're gay because men didn't want pink
well pink is this and pink is that and i
was like no wait a minute
you got a pink tie on
and you're going to try as an image
consultant i'm telling you pink is not a
masculine
color but you draw the line at pink it
skirts but pink ties are okay
this this is a real conversation that
happened and this guy is tall man i was
born in 1970 or something so i'm like
uh-huh but i'll tell you what if russell
westbrook walked in here
i guarantee you the bravado on what you
talking would you look that man in his
eye and tell him man you gay
no because if you do people will be so
mean on the internet but in person they
will not say anything to you
they won't he might he might knock the
chunky soup out of you
oh man why i gotta get down to violence
that's the point
if you gonna call somebody something you
better stand on your disrespect and deal
with the consequences to come into it
but we're so quick to do that because
it's one of the easiest ways
to discredit
a man in particular
in general black man in particular
and reason women do it so much is
they're so used to black men getting in
their emotions and overreacting trying
to disprove it gentlemen
as you become the best version of
yourself and you start to outpace your
competition you might as well expect it
it's going to come you are going to be
called some form of gay learn how to
deal with it and move on
the people who are going to say this
kind of stuff aren't the people you want
to deal with anyway
the women that are saying it recognize
you're out of their league and the guys
who are saying it wish they were in your
league that's usually the reality
so it gives you damn
damn that's actually really true give
access to some of the best insults
that's number one number two
you gotta ask yourself
why do women attack a man's masculinity
when they can't get what they want
why does a why why do why do women
attack a man's masculinity
when they can't get what they want it's
the first thing they go to attack
when you're not paying them the account
of attention when you're not giving
their
first thing they want
you have seen this you have seen people
come on my platform who have had
reasoned conversations with good on
their platform and
shame insults guilt and need to be right
here it comes
you're old you're divorced
you're gay
it's like
do y'all have anything else
no because that's it and that's the
thing you will see people
who will sit there and talk about
something they know is a lie
for hours on end for days on end
so let me address this
front and full kevin samuels is not a
homosexual man
i have never been a homosexual man i do
not like men i am not attracted to men
in the least
anybody who wants to say that they have
something different i want to see you
prove it
not only do i want to see you prove
it let's put something on it
you if if you really believe that i'm
gay all right let's do a lie detector
test let's do all that but here's the
thing
you're going to put up substantial sum
of money so when it comes back negative
i'm walking away with more than just
vindication i want money
why is this important
because going forward i'm going to have
this video sit here as the definitive
response to people who say kevin samuels
hates women hates black women that
videos on monday and this video right
here going forward there is no confusion
there is no well he could be
his sexuality is his business
this is the video you direct them to
anybody who says that going forward is
in my opinion being willfully
disingenuous and dishonest because this
is the official record
because here i even hear guys sit around
saying well you know well we don't know
if he is or isn't but what does that
mean sexuality uh
these are there are some guys that i've
actually talked to and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
be careful when you go down that slope
homeboys
well and what does it matter even if he
was it doesn't make him less talented or
credible because that could be you too
now don't get mad because i dress better
than most of you guys you may not like
my style but you cannot say i don't have
style
and uh this and a lot of this stuff gets
started especially in our community
because this is where i go in with the
guys because so many of our men refuse
to grow up and step into manhood and
masculinity we're still dressing like
boys
you think because you can wear jordans
jeans a graphic t-shirt and a fitted
that makes you a masculine man
not at 40.
unless you are authentically a hip-hop
hip-hop street style personality
which is the smallest style personality
there is you can decide to do it
but it is often inappropriate for your
age
and the particular outcomes you want but
sadly
because it was so tied to the street
culture
and hyper masculinity associated with
gang violence and street violence it's
the one way that black men could
show their manhood
at a distance
sadly we don't see a man in the suit and
recognize that as being the measure of a
man like most groups
you see a man in a dress shirt and some
church shoes or heart social we don't
even know how to call them
you don't even know what to call them
and see that's fine if you're a teenager
even in your 20s but by the time you
reach age 25 personal opinion
professional opinion you need to start
growing your wardrobe up
i've seen far too many men
in their in their late 20s 30s still
dressing like high schoolers oh my gosh
that is so true
guys
women do not care about your shoe
collection i'm just gonna say it
we don't we don't care
it's not attractive to us
if anything to me it's like unattractive
because i'm like why are you spending
that much money on shoes
like what what on earth
and you wonder why you can't command
the respect from the women you want to
so you see people growing these large
beards and tattoos all over the place
and over aggressive masculine
you don't have to do all that
you have to do all that
have to do all that if that's your
choice you can but that's not how we
have to define everybody if you don't
have a big beard and tattoos and all
this other kind of stuff
and see what's funny in my day-to-day
life
this doesn't come up because one thing
that tends to happen is when i see
people out in public one they're
generally shocked at how how big i am
i'm not a small man
six foot four 215 pounds i'm rather
large
and i've said it before
i can take care of myself
so those things really never come up
hell i used to be a bouncer
so again you get access to all the best
insults
and women when they can't get what they
want from it they immediately attack
your masculinity but it's also meant to
keep you mired in the muck it's meant to
keep you it's meant to keep you on
defense it's meant to keep you
justifying what's going on
gentlemen understand something you're
going to have to learn how to let stuff
roll off your back
when you decide to address it if you
decide to address it you need to address
it on your terms one time
uh
one time a couple of times at most and
keep it moving let people say what they
want to say because honestly most of the
people who are your critics and
detractors are not remotely concerned
with the truth
they just want a way to insult you
they want to insult you they want to
insult you and they want to get you off
topic or off task
don't let them
so
but i'm sure there's people out there
who are going to say yeah i hear what
you're saying but i still don't believe
i still don't believe you're not gay
then that's your problem
there's no way to prove
what somebody wants to believe what a
fool believes
but by the same token we can say the
same thing about you
now i will say this before we open the
call line
i think it's kind of crazy that we spent
so much time
with them we seem to be
it's funny because you hear black women
call black heterosexual black men gay
but then you love gay black men
your hair stylist
uh
your best friend
you you see so many women with gay best
friends
so what is it ladies
are you do you not like gay men or do
you love gay men what which one is it
or is it that you're are you really
secretly angry and resentful for the
kind and caliber of black men that you
wish you could get but for some reason
you may not necessarily fit with today
if that's the case then why don't you
adjust what it is you do to get what it
is you want
because these men
are winning i mean i mean i heard what's
kevin
they can't undo three baby daddies
they can't adjust what they're doing
i'm just i'm just playing i'm just
playing but like actually that's why
that's why some of the girls are so mad
because they can't undo
like what they already created
it's amazing how many times
it's almost
to the point where you can look and see
the black men they're going to call gay
if a black man is in a suit
speaks proper english
someone is going to have likely called
that man
you're either gay or you're a sellout
no
i reject that
i believe in excellence so when i see
men like that i see a man a competent
man on his purpose
let's be honest ladies
you're angry
you're angry at the fact
that it's usually when you see somebody
like myself they're telling you
what you want to hear but they're
telling you what you want to hear so
they can sell their products or services
their books or whatever whatever they're
not telling you
what
you want to hear because it's helping
you
now personally i would tell you sitting
in this chair has cost me a lot
it cost a lot to sit here and i never
really share that with you guys
it cost a lot
but i think it's worth it
because having a it cost you in your
business life it cost you in your
personal life
there are people who are like you know
what
i
who want
the amount of scrutiny one person gets
for just sitting here saying
argue having conversations
i think it says much more about where we
are and what we need to get to shout out
to uh mediocre tutorials and reviews
that brother did a video today you know
what i want to play party every day
right now you did a video my gosh i saw
that it was so sad
i was so i'm guessing it's like the one
about him having cancer oh
my heart like oh my gosh
that i think is incredible
uh and it talked basically he was
talking it was
he does some incredible breakdowns
and he juxtaposed me
and several
other people
discussing me and i'm like jesus
if y'all spent as much time telling
women the truth
as you try to spend
judging me
we may actually get somewhere
oh i think he's pulling up a different
video the video is called kevin samuels
versus the thought police
that's
gonna play a little bit of this and
we're gonna open the call lines because
i want to hear from my critics at the
track however i read the room wrong
man i read the room wrong the people who
really think that i'm secretly gay
i'm secretly gay and i hate women so i'm
over here on a down low agenda to to
what in
to what end would a secretly gay man be
talking to women like this what's the
outcome
what's the outcome
to keep men and women separate so men
can get with me i mean
i know we are
a conspiracy
we are prone to conspiracies and
illuminati conspiratorial people
what's the conspiracy
he has an agenda
what is the agenda
keep to keep the women and women in the
gender war going souls to what end
another controversial
and one of the biggest controversies i
tend to hear is i hate women
kevin samuels hates
women
he's a misogynist
he's a misogynist and he hates black
women in particular who hurt you this is
where the whole sign language came from
shame insults guilt the need to be right
keep the likes up folks
so we're going to get into it black
women let's talk about it do i hate you
back in 2013 i interviewed you when i
worked with madame noir
uh and we had you know a viral moment we
talked about black women and boundaries
and you said we were out of order
we're still out of order i don't what up
why
to all my critics and detractors to say
i hate this what do you have for these
women you got this petition you got this
for that okay
we went here and thanos snapped it all
the way
what
what you got
what do you got for women these women
you care so much about
our root chakra is out of control we
have to get our root chakras under
control if we really want to serve the
black sisterhood imma say it again we
got to get our root chakras under
control
i don't
maybe it's because i'm white i don't
know but i do not understand when they
say the black sisterhood because
i mean black girls that are so different
like literally so different
just like you meet white girls that are
so different
like i don't really
like sisterhood
so that we can be of better use to our
women
but many women are very very unrealistic
about their standards for men dating and
marriage
so i'm gonna give my opinion on this and
now listen girls i'm about to be very
raw i'm about to be very real i'm about
to just shoot it to you
as just straight as i can because i'm
hoping that this helps somebody
because as you girls know i'm a
matchmaker and for a large part of
the end of last year and beginning of
this year i stopped matchmaking and the
reason i stopped matchmaking is because
life is i know it is coming to an end
i can't handle female clients i was a
matchmaker that matched females and i
had a few male clients but predominantly
i was matching women
and listen what i it was such a valuable
lesson for me because what i learned is
that
the average woman doesn't really want
just a good man she doesn't want a
husband what she's really wanting are
these standards or ideas that she has of
what a man is supposed to be but this is
nothing what men are there this is not
realistic
for who men are
how they think what they value it's just
this preconceived
you know idea that women have
of who men shouldn't
should be
yeah
there are definitely groups of women
that are very unrealistic so that's so
interesting to hear from a matchmaker
she's like you guys are too much i can't
start out number one
i am a consultant
coach
consultant is coming to an end
i
i want you guys to understand why you
keep hearing that
how dangerous something like that
there are people who are actually
believe
what pastors and preachers say and
there's some fanatical people that i'ma
say it again
you might want to lawyer up be careful
what you talking about because if
something happens
trust me you don't anyway
think about what you
saying the truth now think about the
things that i say and you're going to
hear a lot of things that i say being
said by other people but it's all right
when they do it but when a black man
says it
oh then all of a sudden it's the end of
days you're the antichrist you hate
women you're gay we gotta come on man
the hypocrisy i am not a therapist i'm a
phd
i'm not a therapist
chris i'm not a clinician
i have extensive study in in in
the human mind sociology psychology
anthropology but that's for my own
edification and some training behind
their scenes but i often recommend
people to clinicians so number one if
you ever hear someone saying that he
should have did this instead of that
tell them i he is a consultant
it's sensationalism it's kevin is is
he's got a platform he can give you know
people are tuning in to a show where
it's it's like entertainment it's where
people are tuning in
in order to be able to have
conversations and be entertained
is it coaching
it's not
shut your freaking mouth
you can't go to school to learn what it
is that i do
there's no degree program in the plant
on the planet they can make you
competent at this level
this is earned
avoid the irreverent babble
and contradictions of what is falsely
called knowledge
we got to get our root chakras under
control
i'm not a man of god i'm not i'm i i
believe in god but i'm not a man of the
claw
and more importantly if someone wants my
considered advice in a perfect in a
personal way or a private way
they are free to book a session
how can you say somebody hates women who
sits up here and talks to women day in
day out weekend week out month in month
out put
non-stop you're 24 years old is your
circle your circumstance
there's more to that i want you guys to
go check it out i think it's a great
video
i think it's a great video um
so good on so many levels and i think i
want you to also understand how quickly
people are quick to tell you who you
should listen to
if you ain't listening to them
something's wrong
this is about competition for attention
people this is about power
the power is shifting to
a balanced conversation with the men the
people who are most threatened by my
platform and men like me are people who
have had the microphone and the centers
of power for the longest
no that's so true that's what i think
the manosphere really is is just giving
a voice to men um i think sometimes it
goes too far just like
i think feminism goes too far like i
think they both do
um
feminism maybe a little more but
um
i don't know i think
that what kevin samuels is doing is
actually really great um i think he's
clearly very talented he's clearly very
entertaining and i think even me like
there are videos that i didn't like him
at first um
because of his delivery the way he
talked to people or just some ideas i
don't agree with
but
at the end of the day
i think he's probably the most competent
person like in the man of sphere like if
i had to give
one person like i'd probably say he's
the most competent
maybe there's one or two other creators
that come to my head but
that's what this is about why do you
think these uh attacks keep coming out
it's because of the 20 how many people
over here
the 26 000 people over here if they
could get 26 000 people on a wednesday
night consistently they wouldn't be
worried about what's being said over
here if they could if they could get
women saying you know what i was about
to divorce my husband as a mother of a
wife and a mother of four children i was
about to divorce my husband and get out
here and live my best life in hot girl
summer because i've been listening to
all this popular media and stuff until i
listened to kevin and he hearing him say
that a woman with children has a lower
sexual marketplace value on the open
market and you might want to reconsider
before jumping back out here and then
she actually goes over to a platform and
actually defends me when people are
trying to say about the controversy
around here what's controversial
the outcomes
which of my critics and detractors who
got my name in their mouth so much to
call me gay i hate black women can
produce better results go
if that is you
while you put my name in the title put
your results up show the people who are
saying watching your content in your
video has led me to getting married on
this date
i found my husband on this date i have
healed my relationship and a woman
calling the other day talking about uh
one of your harshest broadcasts one of
my harshest broadcasts um
winter is coming
winter is coming remember that one
one of my harshest broadcasts
her therapist cannot stand me according
to her her therapist is also single and
i believe childless it's not uncommon
for a lot of therapists to dislike me
especially the single childless ones
because they likely see themselves in
the things i'm talking about
i'm a phd
but that woman also shared with me that
she lost her mother
two weeks ago
but she shared with me that she actually
showed that video to her mother and
before her mother died her mother
apologized to her and said he's right
daughter
we did lie to you
we fed you guys a bunch of
misinformation and i am so sorry
so i put the results of these women and
these men up against any of the people
who want to keep calling you gay gay gay
gay well if you want to say gay meaning
happy yes i'm ecstatic at the results
we're getting i'm ecstatic the fact that
you keep my name in your mouth i'm
ecstatic that i am taking up space in
your head for free
you might
i got an airbnb on your channel in your
mind
that's what it is
i got an airbnb on your channel in your
mind my
my my name my platform my content is the
reason you make money and eat
congratulations
true
true
your content literally is the reason i
make money at e i swear to god
i'd say that to him look at it
i clown chase kevin samuels
i ride the kevin samuels clout
train
i don't care
i like to make money okay sue me
sue me i don't even make a lot of money
i'm gonna be honest guys i've been
struggling
struggling
but i make money right
be honest with you you talk about me
because you got no content you got no
solutions nothing else to offer if you
didn't have me to talk about no one
would listen take my name out of your
titles nobody would care
stop trying to expose and this and that
such and so forth when the only thing
we're talking about is the the people
come over here to have consensual
conversations because they're looking
for a better outcome and to be against
that means you for what
what are you for
be honest it's about attention power
pocket watching and a bunch of other
stuff but it's not about getting you
ladies a better outcome understand that
there is a battle going on and it's for
the eyeballs the attention the power and
the resources and revenue that comes
from it
and the sad part is if the people who
actually have the nerve to talk about me
if you really listen to my content
objectively in good faith i find it hard
to think that you will be against the
bulk of what i'm saying even if you
don't like my tone my delivery do you
dislike the outcomes
do you want to be right so goddamn much
that you're no good to anybody else so
if you're right great
if you're right great are you being
right getting anybody what they want we
are better together than apart boys are
reading at the fourth grade level black
women and married rather one in four and
that's including the baby boomers and
their baby boomers
transition on i think the black marital
rate especially among women is going to
drop into the teens the average black
woman makes 37 000
you're going to need approximately 1.5
to 2.9 million dollars to live on
between the age of 65 and 85.
where is that money gonna come from
ladies if you're not married have no
children and no family because social
security won't be here the federal
government got nothing for you and my
critics and detractors will have you
believe that i hate black women how many
of them are telling you about the
reality of what's coming down the line
for you
between 27 and 35 where you need to
focus like a laser on the outcomes you
want with the man it's not to shame you
it's to show you this is the yellow
light if you want to have anything with
a man you better wake up wake up wake up
because after 35 biology starts making
some choices for you
and we don't judge based upon the thing
sometimes i wish girls were like guys
and we just would have forever
i don't like having a time clock it
makes me like
anxious sometimes
and i know the manosphere will be like
good like guys
i get
i get nervous i don't know you judge
them so these are gonna keep telling you
queen diva live your best life take out
your time you don't have all that time
to take you need to decide to get on the
board
so you can have somebody to live with
focus with bill with so you ain't dying
by yourself
and that's what pisses off even people
he talked to him so rude he's this he's
that i am trying to wake you up before
you die alone but like that like like a
boy said
you can do bad all by yourself as long
as you keep coming to church on sunday
and keep it keep your money in that
collection plate
like i said if the church won't black
being back all you got to do is share
power
share power and actually put some
initiatives in towards men and actually
building grooming singles had an entire
program about it i am not your enemy
your your greed and selfishness is your
enemy because you think you're the only
person that knows what the hell is going
on and you're not listening to the men
that come over here you think men out
here are repeating me
no i'm actually repeating them in
none of the stuff i'm talking about that
i make it up i have my own unique spin
on it
barber shop basketball court gym men
have always talked about this stuff
been talking about this stuff since the
bpu at the university of oklahoma back
in the 80s the transition to the houston
tillerson cultural center black men's
laments have always been the same we won
a woman is fit feminine friendly
cooperative submissive childless
can you at least be nice to us that's
all you're really asking can you be nice
and feminine
and preferably no children
and now we got women who will tell you
they only want to smile at black men so
they'll feel like you're being put apart
so you're going to tell me that i hate
women when you what do you tell the
women who think they shouldn't even
smile at a man who helped build this
world that they take advantage of
and then when somebody actually has the
nerve to say something sit down and
actually have a consensual conversation
the first thing you want to do you call
that man gay gay gay gay gay gay okay
all right great right so if that's the
case that you don't care about my black
mother my black the black women in my
family think my you don't care about any
of that let's be honest
you need me
you need me on that wall you want me you
need me you need somebody to be a foil
you need an enemy you need somebody to
rail against because without me your
life is empty
if you don't have somebody to say that's
the bad guy that's the bad guy right
over there you got nothing when i was
gone for two weeks all you heard was
trail
from the critics and detractors and the
reactions and this and that why
look at it don't
let me clock chase in peace okay gosh
that should tell you they have nothing
for you ladies
gentlemen
understand
part of the reason it is such a
disconnect between the women and the men
today is because too much [ __ ] out
there
guys um
sorry i just got like
some like news um
i just like i don't know um
i'm just gonna like end this for now
um
i'm sorry i'll like
do a different reaction video like a
different day